[Musique]
puis
cass
[Musique]
à
we can
[Musique]
ça y est le trailer prévu pour star wars
8 est enfin sorti beaucoup
d'informations nous sont communiquées
par le biais de ce dernier mais surtout
de nouvelles théories font surface
et puisque mon premier trois théories
sur cet opus commence à devenir un petit
peu obsolète
enfin les théories reste toujours
cohérente tout de même j'ai décidé de
vous proposer trois nouvelles théories
totalement personnelle en grande partie
inspiré par le trailer sortie imminente
allez c'est parti je ne vous cache pas
que je suis très hype écart star wars il
va probablement être une innovation de
la saga star wars
puisque pour la première fois le héros
principal maîtrisera les deux côtés de
la force
je m'explique si nous nous intéressons
au trailer de star wars 8 nous entendons
lui querrey communiqué luc lui demande
ce qu'elle voit bien évidemment en
rapport avec la force et ray lui répond
qu'elle voit la lumière et l'obscurité
pour finir par répondre qu'elle voit l'
équilibre de la force
ceci nous met directement la puce à
l'oreille est ce que rêve va devenir une
jedi gris le terme de jedi gray est
assez confus car elle peut désigner un
pratiquant de la force maîtrisant côté
lumineux et côté obscur sans être séduit
par le second ou bien un ancien jedi qui
a quitté l'ordre car elle n'était plus
d'accord avec les idéologies de ce
dernier mais qui ne devient pas un site
pour autant il reste un jedi nous
pencherons donc pour le premier cas de
figure réapprend la force aux côtés de
luc comme je l'avais annoncé cependant
le cas l'air de lui apprendre les deux
côtés de la force pourquoi
déjà nous le remarquons car l'udc
mentionne bien un vrai que l' équilibre
c'est bien plus grand que sa nuque
maîtriserait donc les deux côtés de la
force en croire ces paroles mais
pourquoi luc maîtriserait les deux côtés
de la force
je vous rappelle que l'udc a formé une
académie de djeddah et avant star wars
est cependant des adeptes du côté obscur
sont apparues suite à la formation de
nouveaux détails
l'udc n'avait pas compris la leçon je
vous rappelle khanaqinne devenu dark
vador avaient ramené un certain
équilibre en tuant tous les jedi et dark
sidious cependant l'ucl a complètement
faussé avec son académie jedi qui du
coup a engendré des partisans du côté
obscur sans parler de snacks luc aurez
donc compris que pour maintenir
l'équilibré il faudrait se situer entre
le côté lumineux et entre le côté obscur
et c'est ce qu'ils enseignent arrêts il
faut noter une évolution de la force le
côté lumineux le côté obscur fait perdre
et commence à se confondre le cas très
bien compris que l'un engendre l'autre
et qu'il faut se battre au milieu car
c'est le meilleur moyen de devenir plus
puissants red viendrait donc une jedi
gris maîtrisant côté lumineux et côté
obscur elle est un personnage pour ré et
plein de bonne volonté de courage mais
elle reste très apeurée est trop
attachée à jack ou d'ailleurs des
éclaircissements sur d'identité de ses
parents seraient dévoilées dans star
wars
8 c'est d'ailleurs un star wars qui va
nous donner beaucoup de réponses sur le
passé de star wars 7 sur l'exil de
luxure en solo et les ja et du coup les
parents de ré pour finir sur cette
théorie le trailer nous montre bien que
rêve l équilibre dans la force qui est
enseignée par lui que cela ne
m'étonnerait pas et serait un tournant
pour la saga star wars que ray devienne
une jedi cri pour amener l'équilibré
autrefois perdu par luke skywalker et la
venue de snook
bon les amis maintenant nous allons
parler d'une théorie complètement
farfelu imaginé par mes soins et de
certains abonnés et c'est franchement
celle qui me rend mon âme d'enfant tout
excité et si star wars 8 l'annoncé d'un
retour d'anakin skywalker obi-wan et
yoda voir d'autres je m'explique
quelque chose dans la nouvelle saga
m'interpelle énormément la voix d'obi
wan est présente dans star wars est
durant la vision de ré et dans le
nouveau trailer d'anciennes voies refont
surface
nous avons le célèbre obi wan kenobi
vous êtes mon seul espoir de l'eia elle
parle d'ailleurs d'obi wan et ceci
pendant que red hill lumière vous allez
voir que j'énonce pas ça par hasard
ensuite une deuxième voix retentit c'est
celle d'obi wan 10 ans séduits par le
côté obscur
on pourrait alors penser que cela parle
de dark vador soit d'anakin autrefois
ceci encore une fois pendant que ray
parle du fait qu'elle voit l'obscurité
puis quand elle énonce équilibre une
dernière fois fait surface c'est celle
de yoda disant il nous entoure
il nous relie cette phrase parle d'après
moi des mythiques laurier un soin de la
force ou bien justement de la lumière et
l'obscurité énoncé auparavant qui
entoure chaque être dans la galaxie et
qui justement relie les jedi et les sith
je ne sais pas si je vous ai perdu dans
ce que je voulais dire qu'il serait
possible qu'un retour d'anakin d'obi wan
ou encore yoda fasse surface
pourquoi ça je sais que cette idée est
totalement farfelu mais c'est mon âme
d'enfant qui vous parle
anakin obi-wan et yoda ont atteint et
trouver l'immortalité en renaissant en
tant que fantôme
ils sont présents à la fin de star wars
6 ils sont face à lui
l'udc s'est exilé sur une planète pour
justement trouvé le premier temple jedi
peut-être pour retrouver des aïeuls ou y
venir en aide et apprendre de façon plus
précise la force
cela ne m'étonnerait pas du tout vu que
semble apprendre arrêt à maîtriser les
équilibres de la force soit aussi le
côté obscur l'udc ne connaît rien au
côté obscur à la base et a certainement
appris à maîtriser une partie grâce à
son défunt père anakin sous forme de
fantôme
vous ne trouvez pas ça bizarre
d'entendre les voix d'obi wan de yoda ou
autres personnages dans star wars est où
la nouvelle bande annonce peut être que
ces répliques sont plus de là pour
approfondir l'idée proposée comme
l'obscurité séduits par le côté obscur
comme dit obi-wan reste serait peut être
séduit par ce bord là mais j'ai envie
d'y croire la voix de be one est
présente dans trois sets lors de la
vision de ré et pendant le trailer de
star wars 8
ce n'est pas un hasard et de nombreux
indices cachés sans le faire partie de
ces derniers d'ailleurs l'acteur
d'anakin hayden christensen pourraient
être soupçonnées de revenir dans star
wars 8 mai dans le but de faire des
flashbacks avec dark vador
mais ce n'est pas sûr mais qui sait j'ai
envie d'y croire et comme diraient nos
amis naciri alors j'ai envie
je te le dis je te crie bref à vous de
me dire votre avis mais cela ne vous
fait pas rêver car moi oui
[Musique]
il est temps pour les jedi d'en finir
voici la phrase a plus intrigante est la
plus intéressante de ce trailer que veut
bien te le dire comme nous n'arrêtons
pas de le répéter depuis le début de
cette vidéo il se pourrait que l'udc
devienne une sorte de djeddah et gris
toute façon il est obligé de le devenir
car l'ordre jedi n'existe plus et bien
évidemment ray en deviendrait une aussi
cependant pourquoi pour l'est jedi d'en
finir
plusieurs cas s'offre à nous
rappelez-vous de mon trois théories sur
la fin de la saga
ce titre est vraiment ambigu car l'udc
est normalement le dernier jedi
cependant en rêve à maîtriser la force
aussi alors à ce qu'elle serait
considérée comme une jedi
je ne pense pas juste qu'elle va
maîtriser les deux côtés donc le quai le
seul entre guillemets derniers jedi
vous voyez donc où je veux en venir
d'autres jedi sont encore présents il se
pourrait que d'autres jedi existe
toujours et se cache dans l'univers tel
des ermites et qu'il se cache dans
d'autres temple jedi vous trouvez pas ça
étrange que dans le set l'udc soit le
dernier jedi et que dans huit cela
change pour devenir l'est derniers jedi
cela cache quelque chose la théorie la
plus probable serait que lors de son
académie il y ait eu des survivants
suite à la rébellion de kay lorraine et
que c'est jedi se soit caché ou bien
êtes été caché par luc lui même tout
comme lee et les ja à leur naissance
avez vous compris ce que le site vous
faire comprendre reste semble posséder
un lien particulier avec l'udc et la
force qu'elles sont déjà maîtrisé sauf
qu'elle ne s'en rend pas compte
rae a été abandonné sur jack ou à sa
seule survie est probable que le coca
chéret sur jack ou pour la protéger de
cette rébellion et surtout de kay
lorraine mais elle ne serait pas la
seule
d'autres g dames plus âgées auraient été
cachées par l'udc sur d'autres planètes
pour les sauver reviendrait en force
pour combattre aux côtés de leurs
anciens mai
un combat seraient alors créés entre kai
lorraine et les chevaliers de rennes
puis lui qu'avec ses ancien apprenti qui
auraient survécu
d'ailleurs la phrase du temps pour les
jedi d'en finir nous montre bien que
l'udc aurait compris l'erreur qu'il a
fait de créer une nouvelle académie et
qu'il est temps de ramener l'équilibré
dans la galaxie en arrêtant key lorraine
est ok mais aussi la disparition des
derniers jedi qu'il aurait formé il est
temps que l'ère des jedi cesse d'exister
ce serait pourquoi luc apprendrez arrêt
à maîtriser l'équilibré entre lumineux
et obscurité
a vous de me dire ce que vous pensez de
tout ça il est possible que les derniers
jedi concerne simplement en retz et
l'udc mais j'ai envie d'y croire
cette vidéo est purement subjective et
traduit ma simple pensée que je
souhaitais vous partagez star wars 8 me
fait rêver depuis plus d'un an et je
suis fier de vous avoir fourni une vidéo
parlant de ce trailer
merci à ceux qui penseront au cous bleus
et qui partageront la vidéo c'était
targue rock que le liner soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]